à commencer par le style jean pierre
foucault qu'était je les trouvais très
beau magnifique jean-pierre il était
bien bronzé il vient bien habillé il
était classé reposer reposer il est bien
reposé et bien que ce qui se passe est
ce qu'elle a dit elle a entraîné cette
pêche là d'une saloperie non non pas du
tout
non non bah oui bien sûr ça fait des
décennies qu'on présente miss france
alors je le connais bien moi je sais
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a dit moi qui
étais en robes à elle enregistré toute
façon il sera demain on peut alors je
m'en vais je n'ai aucune mesure deux
fois je suis partie un jour avec
ardisson tu as vu il était devant moi
pour rappel on va pas voulu mettre à
côté je viens d isabella a laissé partir
regarder le studio clamp miss france
2010 9
c'est parti pour le show alors est ce
que nos amis sont prêtes ou pas il a
vaincu donc je vais vous chanter une
chanson devient du coup ces deux groupes
c'est le cirque
on est bien d'accord pardonnez moi je
dis au revoir bien entendu aux autres
miss
je suis tellement triste de voir partir
les demoiselles m 6 bonheur il faut que
je comble me dit-on délicatement dans
mon oreille gauche je vais donc comblé
un match erding est ce que vous êtes
combler vous même
jean pierre foucault comment allez vous
trouver jonquière allez vous nous avez
mis tous des notes vous avez pas tous
réagir un heureux jean pire j'en perds
ça c'est un exemple pour toi je re
stéphane oui oui oui c'est ce qui vous
est à peine jean pierre oui c'est mon
dernier mot mais rick hunter moi aussi
alors je trouve qu'il est élégant et en
plus élégante toujours avec ses invités
avec les gens qui s'adressent il fait
attention les bep couture
j'aime beaucoup jouer alors vous allez
me disent on va pas faire tout les
nôtres dix mois pour moi c'est ma
madeleine de proust il est le programme
il faut qu'il reste à la tête de miss
france et je pense qu'il est bien seul
voilà je prenne ma sensibilité vrai
clavier alors il ya décide vite et bien
justement ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
son plein sur les réseaux sociaux et
vous attendez la moins bonne note les
gens me si oui parce que je trouve
qu'elle a un petit côté je m'en foutiste
un peu jean d'illac et chouette ça
manque un peu pour les flics sont là le
mérite peut-être un peu plus de dalles
en veut plus mais je réside à bruxelles
en tant que candidate en tout cas je
l'avais trouvé très pâle et très avenant
avec nous très sympa c'est un amour
franchement c'est un amour gilles diss
il a sauvé la cérémonie du naufrage non
mais moi je trouve qu'il est absolument
parfait justement moi j'aime bien ce
côté qu'il acquit là où au fil des
années maintenant se tourner de plus en
plus des tâches et je suis là et je
m'amuse et il ya du second degré
d'ailleurs à un moment il dit on dit de
combler hors jeu mais kovalev était
ravie voilà il est vraiment il incarne
le programme à challans edison edf toi
comment tu la trouves exemplaires ça me
fait bien une fois il n'ya qu'une fois à
lyon il a pointé bien ouais pourquoi là
parce que c'était une grande salle et
puis il y avait obispo et jannier
holiday et obispo était pas là ovi store
guerre qu'il a passées à la salle est
parti en vrille parce que il n'a pas
manqué de bonjour et jean-pierre il fait
un bras d'honneur et rentrer dans les
coulisses pendant qu'il y avait
un bruit infernal sans la salle c'est le
direct gérard collomb est venu me voir
en me disant veille au maire de lyon la
maire de lille mais redevient exactement
il est venu ici c'est vous qui fournit
dans les coups dit eh ouais je suis
arrivé j'ai dit je vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]